[Music]
hi everyone I'm United in Toronto and
I'm here to tell you a bit about our
studio comp 2019 and specifically the
train the trainer workshop I'll be
giving ahead of the conference this is a
two-day workshop and on the first day I
will be joined by my colleague Garrett
Gollum and to teach you how to teach
short our courses and workshops on the
second day you'll have the choice of
choosing between the two tracks how to
teach SHINee which will be taught by me
and how to teach the tidy verse which
will be taught by Garrett this workshop
is a rare opportunity for those of you
who are considering branching out from
using art to also teaching art as well
as those who already might specialize in
teaching art but would like to improve
I'm calling this a rare opportunity as
many trainers and educators often go
from being practitioners to teachers
without training in between about how to
teach this was certainly true for me at
the beginning of my teaching career
however I found workshops books and
other resources on how to teach more
effectively to be incredibly helpful for
improving my own teaching therefore I'm
very excited to share what I know about
teaching our and shining with all of you
I'm also super excited about the
opportunity to spend two days working
with teachers of our so what did you
expect from the train the trainer
workshop on day one of our workshop we
will discuss best practices pedagogical
choices and tips for creating effective
examples and activities more
specifically we will present practical
activities that you can use immediately
to improve your presentation style
learning outcomes and student engagement
the goal is for you to leave the class
with a cognitive model of learning but
you can use to develop your own
effective workshops or courses within
your organization additionally we will
cover how to use our studio cloud and
its curriculum of tutorials to jump
start your own lessons on day two we
will ask you to make a tough choice do
you want to learn more about teaching
SHINee or teaching the tidy verse those
who pick SHINee will join me for a full
day of training on teaching SHINee
at the beginner and intermediate levels
over the past I have developed and
taught a variety of shiny courses and
workshops both in-person and online we
will build on materials from these
courses and workshops as well as from
the upcoming book on shiny by Joe Cheng
the creator of the shiny package and
share examples that cover the entire
lifecycle of a shiny app that is built
improve and share a huge bonus of the
workshop is that you will receive the
course materials for teaching mastering
shiny our Studios today shining workshop
additionally participants will receive
the art studio certified shiny
instructor certificate this workshop is
for you if you're a training partner or
want to become one or if you're
interested in the certification or if
you're an advocate for our in your
organization we expect participants to
be proficient with shiny coming into the
workshop please visit the conference
website to learn more about my and
others workshops and I'm very much
looking forward to seeing you all in
Austin
[Music]